>>> THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE
HAS RELEASED ITS FINAL REPORT,
IT'S 845 PAGES.
THIS DOCUMENT IS BASED ON MORE
THAN 1,000 INTERVIEWS, EMAILS,
TEXT MESSAGES AND YEAR AND A
HALF LONG INVESTIGATION, AND
THIS IS WHAT THEY FOUND.
THEY FOUND EVIDENCE HAS LED TO
AN OVERRIDING AND
STRAIGHTFORWARD CONCLUSION THE
CENTRAL CAUSE OF JANUARY 6th WAS
ONE MAN, AND THAT IS FORMER
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP WHO MANY
OTHERS FOLLOWED.
NONE OF THE EVENTS OF JANUARY
6th WOULD HAVE HAPPENED WITHOUT
HIM.
LET'S BRING IN FORMER WHITE
HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY, SARAH
MATTHEWS.
SHE RESIGNED ON JANUARY 6th AND
TESTIFIED BEFORE THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE.
THIS IS AN EXTENSIVE REPORT NO
DOUBT.
THE COMMITTEE PLACES THE BLAME
RIGHT AT THE FEET OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, TRUMP, FOR THIS
INSURRECTION, AND THEY CONCLUDE
HE SHOULD BE BARRED FROM OFFICE.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THIS REPORT
IS THE NEXT STEP IN
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE FORMER
PRESIDENT AND DO YOU BELIEVE HE
SHOULD BE BARRED FROM OFFICE?
>> I DO AGREE WITH THAT
ASSESSMENT.
I THINK THE REPORT SHOWS THIS
WAS A VERY ORCHESTRATED EFFORT
BY TRUMP AND HIS CO-CONSPIRATORS
TO TRY TO OVERTURN THE ELECTION
AND THAT ON JANUARY 6th IT
PLAYED OUT EXACTLY HOW DONALD
TRUMP WANTED IT TO.
HE SAT BY AND WATCHED AS THE
RIOT UNFOLDED AND NEVER ONCE
PICKED UP THE PHONE TO TRY TO
CALL FOR HELP.
EVEN WHEN HIS OWN VP WAS UNDER
ATTACK.
SO I DO THINK THAT HE SHOULDN'T
HOLD OFFICE EVER AGAIN AND I
HOPE THIS REPORT NOW, YOU KNOW
THAT DOJ WILL HAVE ALL THE
EVIDENCE THAT THE COMMITTEE HAS
COLLECTED, WILL GO FORTH AND
HOPEFULLY DO SOMETHING WITH IT.
>> SARAH, I'M SURE YOU'RE NOT
SURPRISED THAT YOU'RE IN HERE,
RIGHT.
SO THERE IS ONE PART IN YOUR
INTERVIEW WITH THE COMMITTEE
WHERE YOU TALK ABOUT YOUR
REALIZATION THAT TRUMP WAS
SAYING ON JANUARY 6th THAT IT
WAS INDEFENSIBLE.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO PEOPLE, SOME
OF YOUR FORMER COLLEAGUES OR
MEMBERS OF THE GOP WHO STILL
DON'T SEE WHAT HE DID WAS WRONG?
>> IT IS DISAPPOINTING TO SEE
THAT, YOU KNOW, SOME OF MY
FORMER COLLEAGUES DON'T HAVE THE
SAME OPINIONS ON JANUARY 6th
THAT I DID.
ON JANUARY 6th, I KNEW THAT
TRUMP'S BEHAVIOR WAS
INDEFENSIBLE AND AT THAT TIME I
DIDN'T EVEN HAVE A FULL SCOPE OF
THE WHOLE PICTURE.
SO NOW SEEING EVERYTHING THAT
THE COMMITTEE HAS UNCOVERED AND
TRULY SEEING JUST HOW MUCH TRUMP
DIDN'T CARE AND IT WASN'T EVEN
THAT HE DIDN'T WANT TO ACT -- OR
IT WAS THAT HE DIDN'T WANT TO
ACT, HE DIDN'T CARE ABOUT THE
RIOT UNFOLDING AND IT WAS
INDEFENSIBLE, HIS BEHAVIOR THAT
DAY AND MORE SO HIS BEHAVIOR
SINCE THEN.
HE NEVER FELT ANY REMORSE FOR
HIS ROLE IN JANUARY 6th AND
CONTINUES TO PUSH HIS LIES THAT
THE ELECTION WAS STOLEN.
>> I WANT TO READ OTHER STUFF
BUT QUICKLY WAS THIS THE FINAL
STRAW FOR YOU OR WAS THERE --
WERE THERE THINGS THAT LED UP TO
THIS OR DID YOU AT THIS MOMENT
HAVE AN E IF YPHINANY AND SAY IT
DO THIS ANY LONGER?
>> IT WAS A SLOW BURN FROM
ELECTION NIGHT.
I KNEW ON ELECTION NIGHT WE WERE
GOING TO LOSE, WHEN GEORGIA
WASN'T TRENDING OUR WAY IT
DIDN'T SPELL A RECIPE FOR
SUCCESS.
I KNEW THEN WE HAD LOST.
>> OKAY.
>> AND I THINK THEN THE
PRESIDENT CHOSE TO PURSUE
LITIGATION AND EVERYTHING.
I HAD HOPED ONCE THAT LITIGATION
FAILED HE WOULD PROCEED WITH THE
PEACEFUL TRANSFER OF POWER BUT
WHEN WHEN JANUARY 6th CAME
ABOUT, OBVIOUSLY THAT DID NOT
HAPPEN.
SO IT DEFINITELY WAS A SLOW BURN
FOR ME AFTER THE ELECTION.
BUT ON JANUARY 6th, HIS BEHAVIOR
WAS DEFINITELY THE FINAL STRAW.
>> GOT IT.
YOU TOLD THE COMMITTEE THE
FORMER WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY, KAYLEIGH McENANY FELT
UNCOMFORTABLE PROMOTING THE
CONSPIRACY THEORY AND THE
PRESIDENT TOLD HER TO TALK ABOUT
THAT AT THE INTERVIEWS, HE DID
REQUEST HER TO DO BRIEFINGS ON
IT AS WELL, BUT DID NOT.
WHY DID SHE FEEL SO
UNCOMFORTABLE TALKING ABOUT
DOMINION CONSPIRACY THEORIES?
>> SHE KNEW AS I KNEW, I THINK,
THAT THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE TO
PROVE THOSE CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
SO THAT WAS SOMETHING SHE WASN'T
WILLING TO SPEAK ABOUT IN
INTERVIEWS, AND OBVIOUSLY WOULD
NOT DO IT FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
PODIUM, TOO.
AND SO THAT WAS SOMETHING THEN
THAT WE TRIED TO ACTIVELY AVOID
THE PRESIDENT IN THOSE DAYS
AFTER THE ELECTION BECAUSE HE
WAS PUTTING THAT PRESSURE ON HER
TO TRY TO GO OUT THERE AND SPEAK
ABOUT THIS.
>> A COUPLE THINGS QUICKLY.
DID YOU EVER HEAR ANYONE TELL
THE PRESIDENT THAT HIS THEORIES
ABOUT DOMINION WERE WRONG?
>> I WAS NEVER IN THE ROOM FOR
THAT, BUT I DID KNOW THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT THE LAWYERS WERE
COMMUNICATING TO HIM ON THE
CAMPAIGN SIDE.
>> OKAY.
THE COMMITTEE HAS PUT FORWARD
EVIDENCE THAT TRUMP KNEW THAT HE
LOST THE ELECTION.
YOUR FORMER COLLEAGUE, CASSIDY
HUTCHINSON, TOLD THEM THAT MARK
MEADOWS SAID TO HER, I QUOTE
HERE, A LOT OF TIMES HE'LL TELL
ME THAT HE LOST BUT HE WANTS TO
KEEP FIGHTING IT AND HE THINKS
THERE MIGHT BE ENOUGH TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION.
DO YOU THINK, SHOULD MEADOWS
HAVE PUSHED BACK MORE ON THE
PRESIDENT?
>> I DO THINK SO.
I THINK MEADOWS KNOWS BETTER AND
I WAS THINK HE WAS ONE OF
TRUMP'S BIGGEST ENABLERS IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
AND IT'S DISAPPOINTING, GIVEN HE
WAS IN THE ROOM AND HE CHOSE TO
JUST, YOU KNOW, ALLOW TRUMP TO
PURSUE THESE CRAZY CONSPIRACY
THEORIES RATHER THAN SWATTING
THEM DOWN.
THAT'S WHY I THINK YOU SAW TRUMP
TURN TO THE PEOPLE THAT WERE
FEEDING HIM THESE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES BECAUSE THE FOLKS THAT
WERE TELLING HIM THESE WEREN'T
TRUE HE STOPPED LISTENING TO
TOWARDS THE END OF HIS
ADMINISTRATION.
>> QUICKLY, THE TRUMP ATTORNEY
THAT THE COMMITTEE IDENTIFIED
HERE, KENNETH CHESBRO BEING THE
ORIGINAL ARCHITECT OF THE FAKE
ELECTORS PLOT DID YOU HEAR ABOUT
THAT?
>> I DID NOT.
THAT'S NOT A NAME I'M FAMILIAR
WITH.
>> THEN THERE'S JACK SMITH, THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL, HAVE YOU
OFFERED TESTIMONY IN THAT
INVESTIGATION?
HAVE YOU HEARD FROM THE
INVESTIGATORS?
>> I HAVE NOT.
THEY HAVE NOT REACHED OUT TO ME.
>> SARAH MATTHEWS, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
I APPRECIATE YOU COMING ON.